Why do people continue to eat food that's full of toxic chemicals
over eating, like,
real, natural food?
For example, my mother in law and my husband refuse to use maple syrup
when I make pancakes, waffles, whatever.
They legit refuse. So I have to have maple syrup for my,
me and my kids, and then I have, like,
Missus Butterworth or whatever,
you know, for.
For them in the pantry. And this has been going on for a few years now.
And, you know,
I'm not like, you can't have that in my house.
I prefer it wouldn't be there.
I prefer fake syrups not be used.
Um, sometimes my kids will accidentally use it,
and I'm, you know,
I'm not having a freak out about it,
but it's just. Why do you want it?
Why would you want to use that over maple syrup?
Like, I just.
I don't understand. It's like,
Maple syrup taste amazing.
Like, who doesn't not like maple syrup?
I understand why you'd buy fake syrups over maple syrup
if you feel like, price wise,
it's cheaper. It's something that people did in the 90s,
you know, in the early 2,
like, nobody even pointed out that these fake syrups are bad for you.
But now we know better, and we know maple syrup is better,
so why not just eat it? The other day,
I made pancakes, and I had thrown the Mrs.
Butterworth away. It got tipped over in the pantry.
It's Been there for however long?
Um, a few years.
And my husband's currently deployed,
so there's no one really, to eat it,
and I just threw it away.
And then we all had sat down to eat the pancakes.
I just made, you know,
raw buttermilk, homemade pancakes from scratch.
And the maple syrup was on the table.
And she, you know,
got really upset that the missus bathorus was missing,
and she just didn't use syrup.
She'd rather just eat a dry pancake.
Like she ate a dry pancake
because she'd rather have a dry pancake
than have maple syrup on her plate. I'm just baffled.